let's talk about the reaction that they
had when uh an MSNBC crew if you can
pull up this video so they're sitting
there if you can zoom it in like yeah
there you go so they're talking about an
announcement that DeSantis makes the
person of the year shortlist you need to
see the reaction of what they say when
that is announced check this out
a22 winds down we are beginning to
reflect on the year that was that
includes the highly anticipated
revealing of times annual Person of the
Year Ron DeSantis makes no sense to me
explain this no I can't do the Dow of
status but his presence on the list is
because he won re-election in a massive
land side he flipped Miami-Dade and much
to the Chagrin of a prominent former
constituent is uh on the
cusp of really being the front runner
for the Republican nomination so
zielinski is about to is on the cusp of
winning the largest land war in Europe
uh against the country ten times its
size that's that's the victory that he
has at his side so Roger Sanders won
Miami-Dade County so those are kind of
like the parallel in terms of influence
those are the kind of things we're
really talking about it's it's a
challenge Miami-Dade I don't want to
dismiss Miami Dade it's not like winning
world war three this is my seventh year
leading uh person of the year and I'll
say we do a lot of apples and oranges
comparisons I was gonna say that's why I
guess more like apples and watermelons
fair enough by the way can we back up
and show who was on that short list yeah
is that scrolling right there
are you kidding scrolling on that Robert
I mean I'm sorry Malik uh you got the
FED is that what that looks like or the
Supreme Court you've got Elon Musk
you've got Liz Cheney you've got
zelinski Mackenzie Scott Mackenzie Scott
who's giving away all her money you got
protests in Iran in Iran on protesters
and then who are the who are on the
right you guys can't take the Advocates
and Janet Yellen gun safety how can you
be plural in a in a person of the year
by the way does anybody want to give
their top one or two of who you would
vote for here for person of the year I
mean they've boiled it down to 10 people
DeSantis is on the short list I think
rightfully so who would be here too pick
two off that list that you think
objectively here's the difference though
I think the question is more
who do you think deserves to be there
and who do you think time's gonna pick
because I'll give you my who I think
time's gonna pick I think you know
zielinski is the the one time's gonna
pick because of the way yeah you know
but so okay go ahead so based on that
who do you think is going to be the
topic he's certainly in the front
running here I don't think Liz Cheney
has a chance I don't think uh I I don't
think Janet Yellen has a chance I don't
think that Mackenzie Scott has a chance
what was the one on the left is that the
Iran protest protesters I would that I
put that up I think on a soft spot in my
head in my heart I think that's that's
something near and dear to what we talk
about here I don't think they're gonna
win uh although did you see what the um
the Supreme leaders of Iran are doing
these days maybe we get to that they
might be cutting off the hijab but I
think the Front Runners here are clearly
Elon Musk and zielinski and God forbid
if XI Jing Penguins as well I'd be so
Un-American and Pat I forgot that I
forgot to uh bring this up earlier like
it's kind of weird because the whole I
mean Elon Musk amazed amazing Free
Speech it's killing it I always Adam The
Devil's Advocate I think we've talked
about it yesterday I was reading all
this pen he's giving all these people
all this thing and then all of a sudden
I started hearing about the the neural
link they're about to start testing it
in human beings it's almost as if he's
being this it's like almost it could be
if you want to think like like Devil's
Advocate or wolf in sheep's clothing now
all of a sudden people are gonna go hey
this is the free speech he did that now
he wants to sew microchips in our head
I'm in that's gonna be a great selling
point to people that are kind of
skeptical because Pat it's happening
like they're gonna test I think six
human beings really really shortly and I
don't listen I don't trust anything with
microchips and [ __ ] in the body I'm a
Christian I've read the Bible when they
talk about the mark of the beast it's
getting he might be such a pat he might
be that guy and then it's going to make
people's decision to put these things in
there are you saying elon's the guy
that's gonna be on the top of the list
is that what you're saying he's gonna
probably be up there 100 so Tom who's
who's your name Rob so I'll say I agree
I think Time Magazine is going to make
it zelenski but I'll tell you who I
honestly believe the person of the year
is
um many years ago I was really stirred
when I saw the picture of these people
after they voted remember they would get
the purple dye on their fingers because
they had to put them they would hold
their fingers up in the city Square
defiantly saying I voted which was
equivalent to saying hey come Bonk me on
the head right because it was yeah a lot
of or just cut my head off I actually
believe that the person a year in terms
of the people on that list zelenski you
know I see that but the protesters are
around they're risking everything
they're risking everything and
um all for freedom and a little bit of a
better way and thing you know and uh in
terms of raw impact it's Elon Musk but
the protesters around what they are
putting they're putting their necks out
there for a massive greater good that
they may never see it maybe their next
Generation True by the way Pat you have
a you have a vote yeah I I so if you
look at this I don't know why G is on
the list okay but I I get it you know
he's a name that's got to be on that
list every single time fine notice who's
not on the list Biden's not on the list
kamala's not on the list Obama's not on
any of those guys are not on this which
fine that makes sense okay
um
if you if you look at it from
advancement and controversy and freedom
of speech musk has only been at it for
six weeks so person of the year I don't
know yet I think it's second or third
what the scientists did he had a
Playbook that showed you you know why
it's so
patriotic for what Ron DeSantis did this
is the part we have to respect about
what this guy did it's very hard to have
convictions
where you lead with those convictions
with the risk of you may be very wrong
and it could be catastrophic but you
believe in your bones you're making the
right decision with kids with schooling
with businesses with covid with all of
that and you end up being right I don't
I don't know because what zielinski is
doing 90 of the world is support not 90
most of the world to support every
channel you turn on he's a hero he's a
hero he's a modern-day Western Churchill
every channel mainstream media you turn
on Ron DeSantis is a bad guy so for him
to be right where the NBA held the
playoffs in his state
where Disney World kept doing business
in his State and this land was shut down
where people were going on vacation for
Christmas in his State last year
everybody from La New York Chicago they
were going to Florida for vacation
listen if you truly want to call it
leader of the year
when you leave it person of the year
doesn't necessarily have to be the
leader of the year but if that person of
the year was a leader of the year it's
nobody but Ronda centers on that list
it's not by the way it's not even close
to me yeah you go back it's not even
close he's not having a lucky year go
back and look at the last three years by
the way do you want to consider this
food for thought you want to see Trump
have a meltdown of Epic Proportions if
you want to talk about meltdown what go
ahead Time Magazine select Ron DeSantis
as the Time person of the year Ron
sanctimonious whatever Trump calls him
these days these sanctimonious Trump
would have a literal meltdown why does
he deserve because that's we're heading
towards that point don't you agree that
that DeSantis and and Trump are going to
clash at the RNC and we're going to see
what happens but isn't time
predominantly a left-leaning
organization time Big Time by Mark
benihoff okay then guess what Pat then
what we want different story zielinski
is going to win because how many
billions have they got on the duty
they've set this guy up can I ask why
Mackenzie Scott is in the top 10 list
she's giving away billions of dollars so
so she's given away the money that Bezos
made and that's on the list
and gentlemen no you know I think
they'll pack because she hooked up with
just an average Joe yeah good person Pat
I think you need to normalize it as a
percent and have a different contest
Mackenzie Scott has only given away 33
of the money from her husband there are
women in this country that have given
away 300 of the money their husbands
have generated yeah very true by the way
she's a rookie we're gonna find this out
in the next couple weeks will they
select this I I think so we'll we'll I'm
sure we'll see here so final vote who
are you guys voting just so we can put a
button who's going to who's going to win
okay now odds are on zelinski
who's gonna who's gonna win zielinski
who I would I would hope which I know
they're not are the protesters in Iran
but I think Elon Musk would be second
place and zelinski is going to win it I
think he's the front runner Elon Musk
but protesters in Iran they would have
to have Massa I mean like they would
have to link it yeah yeah I just can't
believe that really pisses me off don't
underplay the vindictiveness of what
Time Magazine will do just to see
Trump's response we'll see so what all
the craziness taking place I believe
future looks bright if you believe
future looks bright get your latest
Future looks bright hat of valutamine it
says future looks right here future
looks bright here we got them in white
we got them in Black we got them in red
are black on black sold out these are
about to sell out if you haven't ordered
one yet we had a person in Michigan but
one then he bought three then when those
three people were in the office they had
to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hats
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody's saying future
looks bright toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
foreign
[Music]